I thought it was at this star I thought
like what are they doing didst
ridiculous handing it to a teenager but
it was actually really cool how the
teenagers stepped up and took charge of
their families budgeting and even cut
costs down and was just like no you're
not having that I think it was a great
concept
it not only showed what it's like to be
an adult but also showed the adults what
it's like to be the kid and so I think
this was a great learning experience for
both the kid and the parent when the
mother the Beggs pissant for the third
bag of potting mix yeah I was just
wanting to see his reaction as well when
the parents thought that he'd only saved
maximum of $100 but he ended up saving
over $800 well the first thing I would
do is definitely keep the bills on so
like there's no power charges and
there's not so we have still water in
the taps and everything I'm pretty sure
that's pretty important next thing is I
definitely put food on the table because
again important I don't want to starve
then the last thing I do is probably
donate some to charity because it's a
good cause and some people need it more
than we do
first thing would be McDonald's every
day and next would probably be games
video games and then just things I like
like scooters like The Sands likes and
stuff like that
[Music]